[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans dimanche
en politique votre émission de débat en
franche-comté je suis ravi de vous
retrouver ce matin pour débattre d'une
question qui concerne tous les salariés
ou presque la fin des 35 heures at elle
sonné pourquoi cette question
tout simplement parce qu à vesoul psa
aps à vesoul les 35 heures ne seront
peut-être bientôt plus la règle alors
est ce pour garantir la survie du site
comme l'assurent psa qui serait la
première grande entreprise française à
se servir des ordonnances macro pour
presser un peu plus les salariés on va
en débattre avec nos trois invités je
voulais prénom tout de suite d'abord
jean paul guilbaud jour vous êtes
délégué syndical cftc à psa à vesoul la
cftc qui représente un gros tiers des
salariés du site vésulien également sur
ce plateau le maire de vesoul alain
chrétien
vous appartenez aujourd'hui au parti
agir la droite constructive
un parti qui soutient la politique du
gouvernement
et puis martial bourquin sénateur
socialiste du doubs vous êtes-vous élus
du pays de montbéliard le berceau de
l'automobile en franche-comté bonjour à
tous les trois bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors
malheureusement certains
ont été sollicités et ont refusé de
venir c'est le cas du medef et de lui et
même nous avions invité des
représentants de ces deux organisations
patronales
malheureusement ils n'ont pas donné
suite alors comme chaque semaine vous
devant votre télé en revanche vous
pouvez participer à l'émission en
interpellant nos invités sur le site de
france 3 franche comté sur la page de
dimanche en politique on a reçu
énormément de questions depuis le début
de la semaine je m'en ferai le relais
tout au long du débat et puis comme
d'habitude vous pouvez commenter
l'émission sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le mot diaz qui s'affiche dit mme paul
fc comme dimanche en politique franche
comté alors messieurs avec ses
ordonnances macron réformant le code du
travail qui offrent ordonnance qui offre
la possibilité à psa de proposer un
accord local d'établissement à ses
salariés ne porteront pas un coup fatal
à la loi sur les 35 heures
alain chrétien du côté je dirais que ça
fait très longtemps que les 35 heures ne
sont plus la règle dans un grand nombre
d'entreprises petites ou grandes
ça fait très longtemps qu'on essaie de
contourner cette loi aussi parfois à la
demande des salariés parce que les
heures supplémentaires défiscalisées
rappelons nous en 1 ça a permis plus de
pouvoir d'achat en contrepartie de plus
de travail moi mais ma ville de vesoul
on est à 37 heures par semaine et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus
raisonner en heure en semaine
il faut raisonner en année en
annualisation du temps de travail il ya
des semaines ont plu travail que trente
30 heures et la semaine suivante il faut
mettre un coup de collier et on
travaille 40 heures donc soyons beaucoup
moins rigide beaucoup plus flexible le
monde a changé en vingt ans elles ont 20
ans les 35 heures je crois un peu plus
maintenant
non elles ont 20 ans le 13 juin 98 voilà
donc la loi a été présenté le 13 juin 90
donc elles ont 20 ans là dans quelques
jours en 20 ans l'économie était
bouleversée elle a changé le e-commerce
c'est aussi une donnée essentielle
aujourd'hui le commerce par internet
progressent avec des chiffres à a avec
13 15% donc c'est quelque chose qui
c'est une donne essentielle à prendre en
compte martial bourquin la loi justement
de 1998 sur la réduction du temps de
travail elle est caduc aujourd'hui pour
vous non seulement il n'est pas caduc
mais les métallos allemands viennent de
se mettre en grève
et d'obtenir 30 heures 30 à 32 heures
sur la semaine du 28 28 heures à 32 eur
plus on aura de productivité du travail
plus la réduction du temps de travail
sera un élément incontournable et ce qui
se fait à vesoul c'est autre chose c'est
la mise en application des ordonnances
macron et j'ai je suis intervenu sur ces
questions sénat pour dire combien elle
était un recul social sans précédent
qu'est-ce qui se passe psa vient
d'enregistrer un bénéfice à des profits
records augmentation de 18%
le patron pdg monsieur tavares il vient
de se faire un salaire assez
impressionnant qu'est ce qu'on propose
aux salariés
si on veut leur les faire travailler
plus on les paye en heures
supplémentaires à 25%
comme tous les ouvriers qui ont
construit leur maison dans le pays de
montbéliard leur encontre les ont
construits ces maisons avec les
ressources ne crois pas qu'on veuille
les faire travailler plus en fait
travailler plus et on veut que les a
augmentées on veut que ça coûte moins
cher ça on veut que ça coûte moins cher
et là c'est là qu'il ya un problème
c'est là qu'il ya un problème quand il y
avait la queue ce choix y compris le
gaullisme social et tout cela
la participation des salariés aux
bénéfices des entreprises est essentiel
ça veut dire que s'il y a des résultats
remarquables on s'approche des marges
des groupes allemands maintenant mais ça
il ya un redressement spectaculaire
on ya joué un rôle parce qu'au moment où
il était au bord du gouffre eh bien on a
on a fait ce qu'il fallait pour le faire
repartir mais maintenant il faut
distribuer et puis pas avoir des accords
connaît salariés ont eu des primes ça
fait deux ans que les salariés ont des
primes d'intérêt alors faut être clair
une prime ça ne compte pas pour la
retraite
le vrai salaire c'est la fiche de paye
et une prime c'est une chose que je
sache c'est pas des primes cas monsieur
tavarez il en a aussi
oui non mais là il a surtout il a
surtout d'un grand salon jean paul gui
un ministre le bourguignon jean baptiste
lemoyne était sur ce plateau à votre
place d'ailleurs
il y a quelques jours on l'a interrogé
sur ce qui se passait à vesoul et il
nous a dit que pour le gouvernement ce
qui était essentiel d'abord c'est le
dialogue social
croyez-vous à vesoul à un accord gagnant
gagnant
alors pour avoir l'accord gagnant je
pense qu'il faut il faut absolument
mettre des contreparties et des
garanties dans cet accord à laquelle
nous avons commencé à négocier la
semaine dernière et nous continuerons
dès demain lundi la deuxième réunion de
négociations
je pense que la vraie question de base c
est ce que si on signe cet accord ça
nous garantit la pérennité d'apéritif la
pérennité du site et que le travail soit
réalisé par des salariés psa il faut
prendre un peu de hauteur où j'entends
les propos de ce bouquin psa va très
bien ça nous en sommes très conscients
qu'à 5 grâce aux salariés d'ailleurs il
faut bien le souligner ou savoir faire
des salariés
ça nous en sommes très conscients
après le paradigme et la changer si je
parle vesoul il ya quelques années
encore cinq ans on était comparée aux
industriels de l'automobile n'est plus
le cas si c'est ce que vous faites à
vesoul ou d'activités très part on est
bien même produisait pas de voiture
non on est centre mondial de la de la
pièce de rechange nous sommes le groupe
distributeur et le master de pau dépôt
europe où nous livrons des puits vésoul
134 plaque dans toute l'europe
donc on stocke de 140 me de références
de pièces toutes les pièces sont celles
de la pièce détachée de la peseta chez
nous sommes allés garage de l'europe
entière on est dans le commerce
voilà donc nous sommes préparés depuis
cinq ans ou monde de la logistique
donc le monde la logistique il est quand
même plus compliqué on se rend compte
que il y a un an on a fait rentrer chez
nous jettent et logistiques pour
reprendre une partie du conditionnement
donc 150 salariés psa reclassés dans
d'autres services
juste pour un coureur qui était à -4 5%
donc il faut bien se rendre compte que
le monde bouge et très vite alors il
faut t'il le faire on rentre en
négociations on prend des contres est
parti parce que à partir de là si on
osait un accord c'est pour négocier
c'est le cas de la cftc unique est ce
que vous pouvez négocier il faut qu'on
galère on vous propose de travailler un
peu plus on va voir les chiffres 1 33
minutes de plus par jour
oui il y en aurait 11 ou 12 qui sont
payés c'est puis le reste qu'il serait
papa
et finalement qui seraient gratuits
entre guillemets son offre face à ce
travail gratuit après c'est un effort
quand même tout à fait alors je pense
qu'il faut qu'on qu'il est plus
d'externalisation ça c'est une chape de
plomb qu'il ya un an sur les salariés
perçoivent soul je pense qu'il faut
qu'ils essaient de garanties dans cet
accord là le deuxième d'accord faut un
vrai plan d'investissement une bonne
organisation du site ça c'est une
obligation
il nous faut un plan d'embauché sur
trois ans aussi on veut que ce soit
inscrit dans le marbre et aussi
l'activité du magasin des gones est ce
qu'on va récupérer magazine pièce obnl
qui est une première sur le site psa
zone
on va voir en octobre et cap arbitré
encore donc on internalise de l'activité
mais où on ne sait pas qui va le
réaliser ça ce sera un accord équitable
pour vous après on va essayer de
renégocier le taux parce qu'on a bien
entendu les salariés tout au long de la
semaine
2,8 pour cent d'augmentation du taux de
base ce n'est pas suffisant ce qu'on
n'est pas je précise
on vous demande de travailler 7 8% de
plus en temps de travail et pour une
augmentation de salaire de 2 8%
oui la direction nous dit ça parce que
pour se préserver les attaques
incessantes de nos concurrents qui eux
sont en moyenne 5% au moins cher que
nous sur le taux de base
on va essayer de renégocier ce taux là
parce qu'on a bien entendu salariés
cette semaine qu'ils veulent qu'il ya un
effort supplémentaire la direction sur
ce point là est ce qu'on veut par dessus
tout si la signature d'accords c'est une
clause de revoyure annuel sur une
période de trois ans pour que s'y est
passé garantie vert au rendre caduque
cet accord alors un accord
gagnant-gagnant certains vesoul y croit
absolument pas vous parliez de ce que
disaient les salariés je vous propose
d'en écouter notamment ceux qui ont
débrayé ces derniers jours les gens font
beaucoup de sacrifices ils sont en
permanence au travail
maintenant ils n'acceptent pas de ne pas
être payés travaillent et 33 minutes de
plus et payer 12 il accepterait on va
rentrer à plus de 21h le soir pour des
moments c'est in ce n'est pas pensable
quoi on a pu voir nos enfants on aura
plus de vie de famille du tout avec nos
enfants fairly de voir tout ça ils vont
être tout seul à la maison
moi mon conjoint travaille d'après midi
aussi on ne sait pas comment on va faire
on s'attendait pas à une telle chose là
mais le travail gratuit
voilà un niveau d'un grand groupe c'est
quand même osé je pense si la porte est
ouverte à vesoul peut arriver à sochaux
elle peut arriver dans les otites donc
sa note quand il n'y a rien qui justifie
cette augmentation du temps de travail
et de dire merci macron parce que
maintenant qu'il est maintenant qu il
est passé il donne le pouvoir aux
patrons aux patrons et maintenant
qu'est-ce qui arrive et ben nous on est
pas pour rien on n'est pas content il
n'a plus rien on n'est pas content on
n'a plus rien cette salariée à la raison
martial burqa emmanuel macron renforce
le pouvoir des patrons avec 16 heures
des riches on le sait avec les décisions
qui ont été prises il s'en cache pas en
plus il assume complètement d'être le
président des riches et on nous a
présenté les ordonnances comme les
ordonnances pour les pme on s'aperçoit
que les pme ne s'en sortent pas bien
comment un sondage qui vient de sortir
qui dit que la confiance vis-à-vis du
chef de l'état est en chute libre
parce que il pense aux grands patrons
pensent à la finance et pas aux salariés
et pas aux petites et moyennes
entreprises
j'aurais par rapport à l'avenir du site
de vesoul
tout dépend d'une chose essentielle
je me suis battu pour cela comme
parlementaires y compris où les choses
se passaient très mal au sénat
c'est la reconnaissance des dessins et
modèles comme parce que régulièrement
même y compris des associations de
consommateurs propose que les pièces
automobiles qui sont notamment celles
fabriquées à vesoul viennent sur le
marché en disant ça coûtera moins cher
ça coûte moins cher au début et ensuite
le site de vesoul disparaissait je me
rappelle on a eu un vote au sénat où là
on s'est rassemblé droite et gauche
je suis intervenu très longuement en
disant c'est la suppression du site de
vesoul
si jamais on supprime les dessins et
modèles et qu'on met en concurrence
parce que derrière ce sont des brevets
derrière ce sont ces de l'intelligence
de la dnat de l'intellect et c'est la
pièce là je comptais une des régions de
france qui produit le must be brevet ou
non au missile ou un garde
si on veut garder ce site de vesoul si
on veut garder le site de vesoul journal
c'est avant tout cela et ça le groupe
psa comme on a été on a voulu que l'état
prenne des parts pour le sauver qu'on
attend on a retrouvé donc fait qu on
allait presque tous et daumas
d'errements à paris avec pierre
moscovici pour sauver groupe psa
ces choses-là faut les faire défendre
des dessins modèles qu'albert vesoul et
en ville
il faut que les salariés bénéficient un
peu de cette embellie le site de
marianne ça devient ridicule
martial bourquin on devient en lisant le
ridicule chez nous psa à vesoul ses 3000
salariés qui se battent au quotidien
pour que le site soit compétitif par
rapport à une économie mondiale les deux
tiers du chiffre d'affaires de vesoul je
pense le contrôle des professionnels se
fait à l'international c'est signé le
temps où le site de vesoul
approvisionner les succursales de la
france
on est maintenant à deux tiers au niveau
international avec des concurrents qui
sont très agressifs mais est-ce que je
suis un chantage à lens que je souhaite
moi c'est pas l'un contient il ya eu un
chantage du royaume c'est pas un accord
de régression que nous souhaitons nous
les élus locaux
c'est un accord de conquête parce que
cet accord doit permettre de faire plus
de chiffre d'affaires d'aller chercher
de nouveaux marchés d'aller chercher de
nouveaux clients qui permettront au site
de vesoul de faire plus de commandes et
d'envoyer plus de matériaux et matériels
partout dans le monde entier c'est ce
qu'on cherche à faire tous ensemble élus
locaux et le l'entreprise 25 % de
chiffre d'affaires supplémentaire en
l'espace de trois ans ça permettra de
créer des centaines d'emplois sur le
site c'est ça la perspective alors alain
côté en a beaucoup on a beau repas de
terroir et une rime à rien at on les
informe tous d'accord à une quête qui
sont plutôt d'accord avec martial
bourquin philippe vous interpelle
directement et vous dis monsieur
chrétien pur style qu'une action
politique constructive consiste à
détruire systématiquement depuis
quelques années en france les
protections et acquis sociaux des
ouvrières et des ouvriers je vais dire
un philippe qui à 20 ans je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on achetait s'était détaché par
internet
aujourd'hui on le fait alors on fait
quoi on laisse faire ça par d'autres on
laisse faire ça par d'autres partial
burqa on laisse faire ça charles et quoi
parler chinois par les allemands parlent
pas non j'ai envie à la fraude était le
chaînon son avis de détacher les six
mois terminés en dieu laissez moi ta vie
je vous écoute avec la protection de
s'échanger le prix est fait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on peut acheter n'importe
quelle caisse par internet
il faut que ce marché là je le fasse
soul et pas ailleurs l'objectif c'est de
capter de nouveaux marchés et de ski ce
qu'on faisait pas aujourd'hui à vesoul
on doit le faire et d'autres le font
pour nous il faut qu'on récupère ses
marchés pour créer de l'emploi
le but de cet accord c'est de créer de
l'emploi de maintenir le site de confort
et j'essaie de créer lire à expliquer ça
aux salariés la barre et puisque
comprennent ça sera beaucoup comprennent
plaisantait néant sûr que si vous
complétez venez à vesoul le volcan
samedi
on va demander à un salarié du cou
jean-paul guille mars 2018 ya deux mois
psa présente ses résultats 2010 est
résultat record en hausse de 20% par
rapport à l'année précédente avril 2018
le mois dernier on apprend que carlos
tavares le pdg du groupe reçoit eu un
bonus d'un million d'euros c'est ça oui
pour le rachat d'opel mais 2018 on
demande aux salariés de psa à vesoul de
faire un effort
est-ce que là il n'y a pas quelque chose
qui interpelle 6 alors ça interpelle
bien sûr tous les salarié es ça on en
débat tous les jours mais au delà au
delà de ça je rappelle quand même la
particularité de vesoul je ne fais pas
l'apologie de la direction ou du
discours de la direction
il faut en tant que syndicat responsable
il faut bien se mettre à la place de
notre site pour le futur de notre site
on est concurrencés quand même dans un
monde de logistique ou amazon fait de la
pièce de voitures aux etats-unis
demain ils vont arriver avec leur
machine de guerre en europe est ce qu'on
saura survivre ça fait 15 ans qu'on voit
des sociétés qui externalisent de droite
de gauche ou débuts en europe de l'est
une quinzaine d'années et depuis 10 ans
5 10 ans en chine et ont ce ne fût ce
que plus quand on voit ça dans les
médias parce qu'on s'est habitué à ça
est-ce qu'on veut ça demain pour nos
salariés
c'est toute la responsabilité est
l'enjeu de cet accord est ce que ça nous
donnera bien sûr pas de garantie à 5 10
ans et on le saura que dans trois ans si
c'étaient de bonnes à côté du nom n'est
pas prêt signé on est prêt à négocier
on est prêt à négocier des choses qui
soient plus gagnant gagnant que ça n'est
à l'heure actuelle avec des gars entier
et on est à l'écouté des salariés qui
veulent qu'on négocie qui le connaît
aussi des choses concrètes pour eux de
garantie et de pérenniser l'emploi sur
le site de psa fait part des salariés
psa florian vous dis c'est toujours la
même chose des gens qui gagnent bien
leur vie demande
ouvrier sans qui l'entreprise ne
pourrait pas fonctionner de faire des
efforts
les temps sont durs pour les ouvriers
nous ne vivons plus nous survivons ya de
ça mais y at-il à rien si on n'évolue
pas si on ne propose pas des références
si on ne propose pas des choses pour
aller de l'avant et bien tous ces
marchés que nous avons aujourd'hui vont
disparaître alors certes on garde nos
acquis on est des conservateurs on
change rien et comme jean paul gui on
voit disparaître des pans entiers de
l'industrie comme si le monde externe
n'existait pas mais juste mais aussi
d'autres pays
jusqu'où ça va s'arrêter on a aussi les
quais sur une autre question francky va
expliquer qu'un jour nos concurrents qui
seront chinois et alors il faudra
travailler pour un bol de riz et dormira
lusine pour rester compétitif jusqu'où
ça peut s'arrêter à la moitié en france
en france en europe et des garanties
sociales en france comme en europe en
train de sauter les unes après les
autres et bien sûr que non martial
bourquin enfin l'accès permanent complet
si vous le populisme le populisme gagne
même c'est quoi j'ai dit julie g c'est
ce que vous dites il faut un discours de
responsabilité soit on ne change c'est
la barre et chansons de change rien
comme on l'a fait depuis vingt cinq ans
ma responsabilité
ont-ils industrie cecos il fondre ses
fournisseurs burqa mais on n'a rien
changé depuis 20 ans et l'industrie a
été divisé par deux en vingt ans faire
parler de ça alors on goûte à ne rien
changer
on peut parler et c'est la faute des 35
heures est bien sûr le problème
compétitivité de la france ce sont les
35 heures en partie leur en grande
partie il faut de la flexibilité du
travail
ça c'est un mot tabou chez les
socialistes pas de flexibilité diamant à
la rigidité en économie ça ne fonctionne
pas il faut être réactif par rapport à
ses clients parler il faut de la qualité
parce que là vous avez une activation
monologue ce succès net c# quand je veux
bien que vous échangez laisser censé
envoyer mon boulot alors simplement
c'est un vocabulaire que s'il y a un peu
vrai y est sensible monsieur fines qu'un
cheveu fini une mission sur l'industrie
je suis à belfort la semaine prochaine
sur ce qui s'est passé avec angie je
vous signale qu'on vient de vendre pour
zéro euro
la branche ferroviaire à simons et s'il
y a un problème c'est qu'il ya absence
d'investissement est plutôt que de
rechercher des accords de compétitivité
quand il ya des moyens comme ça il vaut
mieux investir
est ce que vous savez ce qui est sorti
l'étude d'oxfam sur la rémunération des
actionnaires
il ya quelques les français champion du
monde paolo c'est pas le football à ce
sera dans un mois
champion du monde de la rémunération des
actionnaires
si on allait travailler par la
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est qu'on a une économie de
plus en plus financiarisé et ça ce qui
est visé dedans c'est encore plus de
financiarisation de l'économie
là derrière et surtout la main d'oeuvre
du travail dans le prix d'une automobile
est la moins de 10 % maintenant le
courrier le continu de la manoeuvre a
appris finale du numéro il cessa et
répétées des shows how it moderne faut
on n'observe pas derrière se moderniser
on parle de crise de pièces détachées
chérir ce modèle ne laisse pas la même
chose il ya on ne parlait à construire
des automobiles à parle de faire du
commercial détachées ça ne les rejoigne
et cynisme vous allez lire ce dernie
voilà vous avez des slogans qui ont qui
ont 40 ans qui n'ont pas évolué c'est
pas des clones c'est ce que je vous dise
le bon choix mais l'aîné l'art le
partage où l'on ne parle pas à vesoul de
construire automobile ou z on parle de
faire du commerce des clouds mais jean
paul bué continuer on va repasser on me
propose corps passe la parole à jean
paul ali qui vous écoute moi c'est très
intéressant mais et jean paul gui vous
dites notamment dans les contreparties
qu'ils exigent votre syndicat on veut
des garanties sur l'emploi
et on veut des garanties sur
l'investissement tout ça veut dire que
vous faites confiance à la direction
n'est ce pas non ce n'est pas dire qu'on
fait confiance à la maison soutient
évidemment finances réciproque donc un
accord c'est pour ne pas signer un
chèque en blanc on est bien obligés
d'inclure ces contreparties dans cet
accord pour clean clothes revenus
annuels pour vérifier que nous demande
d'investissement une modernisation parce
que nous avons un site qui vieillit le
monde de la pièce automobile a changé il
faut savoir que avec très peu de
références ont fait beaucoup de chiffre
d'affaires donc il faut se recentrer sur
un des process et une industrialisation
nouvelles de distribution des pièces de
rechange et il nous faut ça pour nous
garantir sa après faut pas oublier et je
le redis depuis que j'étais logistique à
rêver il n'y a pas un jour où ne partent
pas en d'externalisation dans notre cité
on ne veut justement on va voir comment
sont répartis les salariés sur le site
de vesoul vous êtes à peu près 3000
c'est bien ça aujourd'hui il ya deux
mille 300 cdi
oui il ya plusieurs sans vent
voilà envers vous voyez les intérimaires
ils sont 450 environ et puis en bleu
c'est la part des emplois externalisés
c'est-à-dire de d'entreprise de salariés
qui travaillent pour des entreprises
extérieures sur le site de vesoul et ces
dernières années c'est cette part-là de
salariés qui a augmenté
c'est ça votre crainte c'est à dire qu
on externalise au fur et à mesure ces
fonctions là qui sont faites à vesoul
sur la logistique que ce soit plus des
salariés psa qu'ils les accomplissent
des tâches là notre crainte est liée au
dessus de camembert ces sites de psa à
vesoul et non sochaux grave j'ai bien
compris c'est bien le 6 mai non il faut
bien comprendre quand même que c'est
l'habitude d'un wc la ville et cédric
aussi bien mais c'est ce qu'on fait si
on s'attache à faire au quotidien et on
va les rencontrer au quotidien justement
pour pour pour écouter leurs attentes
sur ce show sibilité d'acorn spécificité
c'est la qualité du dialogue social
ça fait des années qu'il ya de l'eau
social moi je suis spectateur qui a un
vrai dialogue constructif
loin des slogans loin du populisme qu'on
peut entendre chez les actrices que et
dia pts 1 mais ça a permis à ses yeux la
direction de psa aurait tenté d'utiliser
les ordonnances macron sur un site où la
cgt majoritaire par exemple il y a
quelque chose de pâtes pourquoi c'est
pas forcément anodin de faire alors de
faire 2 ou luz et force ouvrière et la
cftc justement à vesoul la cgt elle pas
majoritaire posons nous la question
parce que depuis longtemps la vie à une
histoire du si la vie est différente que
ce n'est pas de la production
d'automobiles et syndicats depuis très
longtemps qui négocier de manière
responsable
au coude à coude mais je connais bien
tous les responsables syndicaux qui
négocie actuellement ils sont exigeants
ils savent ce qu'ils veulent pas
d'externalisation + 2 d'augmentation du
point d'indicé savent ce qu'ils veulent
mais savent aussi que tout ça passe par
l'avenir du site de psa et qu'en aucun
cas on doit remettre en cause le site de
psa à vesoul parce que c'est le poumon
économique de tout un département on a
évoqué tout à l'heure le fait que psa
soit la première grande entreprise à se
saisir des ordonnances mâcon pour un
accord
un accord comme celui là est ce que vous
craignez de faire jurisprudence ou c'est
quelque chose que vous avez à l'esprit
aussi on entendait en début d'émission
un de vos collègues de sochaux qui se
disait si ça passe à vesoul
après ils vont le faire partout c'est
une crainte effectivement de nos
collègues d'autres sites on échange par
téléphone qui se disent si on met le
doigt dans l'engrenage à vesoul pourquoi
pas nous demain
après on nous garantit en plus haut lieu
que ça ne sera pas le cas parce que nous
sommes à un site à part et nous sommes
des commerçants nous livrons des pièces
ou plus près des clients et pour les
satisfaire au plus vite et on est
vraiment dans vesoul a toujours été
oublié dans groupe psa faut quand même
pas l'oublier il faut faire l'histoire
on a toujours parlé de la maison-mère de
sochaux qui n'ait plus lieu d'être
sachez maison mais infographie 2 france
3 france convoite non mais de mulhouse
du site d'ugine terminal qui produisent
des voitures et des 43 milles usine de
sochaux
bien sûr et 8,9 me je suis la troisième
génération de psa dans la famille
travail et dont je sois une belle
histoire psa soit dit en passant mais je
pense que vous a toujours été oubliée
parce que on faisait de la pièce de
rechange et le marché de la pièce
d'origine a beaucoup bougé et demain
avec l'électrique et véhicules
électriques ça sera 25% de moins de
pièces de rechange par véhicule il faut
aussi de prendre la donne de demain de
ce que va être le véhicule de demain et
vous faudra être compétitif sur les
marchés intermédiaires et sur le
e-commerce aussi dont on a implanté des
rotors nommé lancé pas que pour aborder
et je partage complètement l'idée de la
diversification nécessaire du site de
vesoul
vous avez raison d'aborder ce problème
mais il ya d'autres façons de l'aborder
déjà un projet industriel qu'elle
diversification mais il existe des
industriels lui dire de ne pas troubler
les y finir mais il finira après la
l'habitude l'émirat après habitués
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'après ce projet
industrialiste où il y aura non il
n'existe il existe le mot j'évolue
demain ou de rien le projet vélo et il
ya ceux qui gèrent elles aussi l'exemple
qu'il ya un sujet il existe
allez-y continuer il est compliqué de
galles il existe il faut lui dire on est
dit si jamais dans un problème laxisme
je vais vous laisser parler vous me
répondrez sur ce projet industriel on
dit quels moyens on y met et sur ces
moyens là quelle est la part des
salariés
là pour l'instant on commence comment on
commence en disant faites attention il
est fragile ce site déjà pour commencer
on va mettre en place cet accord qui est
proposé on fait les choses à l'envers on
a besoin dans l'industrie d'avoir un
vrai projet industriel d'avoir vers
d'aller vers eux
dustrit du futur on n'a absolument pas
avec des investissements diminuent on a
compris que vous étiez pas d'accord mais
une bétonnière le mot gestion s'est
jamais que le site ceja quand il vous
dit j'ai toujours travaillé quarante
heures trente par semaine et pris la
retraite à 65 ans je suis toujours en
vie désolé les temps ont changé aussi
baïla il a raison quand il le dit il ya
dix mais là on entend les idées maman se
disent si je passais au dessus de 35
heures je verrai plus mes enfants parce
qu'on s'est habitué aussi la cee
il ya ainsi eu qui prend en charge aussi
les familles il ya beaucoup de choses
autour de psa qui existe et
contrairement ce que dit monsieur
bourquin le projet industriel il existe
ça fait cinq ans que le site se
transforme qu'on y stocke maintenant des
pneus du trial si ce n'est pas ça aux se
diversifier parce que ça sur ciment sûr
que si tu pourrais arrêter dossier se
pourrait que vous aimez on arrive à la
fin
jean paul vi jean-paul d'y travailler
une demi heure de plus par jour est ce
que ce sera un drame pour les sarries de
vesoul si cet accord est accepté très
vite c'est la conclusion
le drame c'est pas de travailler plus
c'est de réduire le fait d'être de
gagner que 2,8 pour cent le drame c'est
pas les 33 minutes qu'elles ne soient
pas payés dans l'intégralité ce sera le
mot de la fin dans un instant dimanche
en politique continue avec richard
ferrand le patron des députés en marche
à l'assemblée qui l'invité de francis
letellier
ce sera juste après le flash
d'information bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]